bonsoir et ses bovins merci d'être avec
nous une première réaction cette étude
d'amnesty international vous qui avez
d'ailleurs été interpellé en placé sans
être ardent placé en garde à vue
oui bonsoir merci merci pour votre
invitation et effectivement je fais
partie des des personnes qui ont été
interpellées ce 12 décembre et j'ai aidé
amnesty international a préparé ce
rapport justement pour dénoncer ce qui
s'était passé justement cette dérive
policière et toutes les interpellations
abusives ces détentions arbitraires et
donc le place voilà de l'interpellation
de plus 140 personnes qui au final
abouti pour la grande majorité d'entre
elles à à l'absence de poursuite donc
elles ont été relâchées sans lui et sans
la moindre poursuite alors vous juste et
je viens vous l'avocat comment vous
expliquez que vous avez été interpellé
sans avoir été placé en garde à vue bien
écoutez je me les explique pas vraiment
encore aujourd'hui cgt alors j'étais à
cette manifestation qui était donc le 12
décembre contre la loi sécurité globale
et j'étais en tant qu' en tant que
citoyen donc bon de dexter d'extérieur
je n'avais rien pour m'identifier en
tant qu' en tant qu'avocat j'étais
simplement en tant que citoyen j'étais
là pour revendiquer justement là des
libertés pour défendre nos libertés et
parce que je m'indigne est de voir ces
charges abusives des forces de défense
de l'ordre de part et d'autre du du
cortège un moment je me suis fait je me
suis rattrapé par des par les
fonctionnaires de la brave les
voltigeurs de la brave qui m'ont sorti
du cortège et qu'ils avaient décidé tout
simplement de m'interpeller parce que je
parlais un peu trop fort voilà alors
vous avez vu entendu la défense de
gérald darmanin qui lui argumente sur sa
politique de fermeté il dit voilà on a
tout simplement interpellé des casseurs
qui étaient venus pour casser
oui alors ça me fait rire et ça ça
résonne particulièrement bien
aujourd'hui avec le bouvau de la
sécurité qui vient d'être initié où on
entendait justement gérer alternant un
homme parlait de la nécessité pour les
forces de l'ordre de travailler sur
leurs communications
mais on a vu on a vu justement ce
décembre dernier qu'elle était la
communication du ministère de
l'intérieur c'était avant d'avoir même
vérifier la réalité du terrain de
désigner l'ensemble des personnes
interpellées comme des casseurs comme
des violents et donc moi j'étais visé
également j'étais considéré comme un
casseur est comme un ultra violent et on
a vu le résultat de ces communications
qui a été complètement démonté par par
les organisations par les journalistes
qui montrait qu effectivement la plupart
de ces interpellation était sans motif
était complètement abusive et que
c'était juste un coup de com pour
montrer la force du ministère de
l'intérieur
la force du préfet l'allemand sur le
terrain keane comme d'habitude ne veut
pas de contestation et veut mater tout
voilà toute forme d'opposition
est ce que c'est la stratégie tout
simplement du maintien de l'ordre qui
est mise en cause attaqué avant d'être
attaqué c'est pour moi c'est même pire
que qu'une stratégie du maintien de
georges et je fais le constat
aujourd'hui d'une stratégique n'est plus
celle dont l'idée de maintenir l'ordre
mais de refuser tout désordre en fait
donc de cette façon on agit
préventivement
on ne laisse même pas l'opportunité à
des gens de s'exprimer quelle que soit
la façon on les interpelle de façon
préventive
juste parce qu'ils ont une sale tête
juste parce qu'on a décidé
qu'aujourd'hui on ne voulait pas qu'il y
ait de contestation dans la rue
et voilà et donc on est vraiment dans
sur se dispense sur ce glissement
autoritaire sur ce glissement de la
police qui ne cherchent plus à maintenir
l'ordre
mais tout simplement qu'ils refusent
tout désordre pour vous il vous semble
de plus en plus compliqués voire
dangereux de manifester en france ce
n'était pas le cas avant faut placer le
curseur du avant on se rend bien compte
déjà plus de deux ans et avec la crise
des gilet jaune que qu'il est de plus en
plus compliqué de s'exprimer dans la rue
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
effectivement n'importe qui peut être
peut être visé par cette partie cette
répression policière et ça devient très
difficile mais justement moi j'en ai
j'en appelle aux gens pour continuer à
être dans la rue c'est extrêmement
important
on peut pas laisser cette dérive cette
dérive s'installer
nous c'est une liberté fondamentale que
d'être dans la rue que de pouvoir
s'exprimer sa fin mais ça fait partie de
nos droits et et la démocratie et le
gouvernement doit l'entendre tout
simplement
justement j'ai appuyé sur l'avant parce
que ma pensée c'était avant cet épisode
de gilet jaune
en quoi cette séquence cet épisode at il
justement changer la donne ait changé la
politique du gouvernement en la matière
selon vous balance ses bas ses fins et
une scène résulte en fait d'un d'une
tension qui est de plus en plus
importante entre le gouvernement et on
va dire la base sociale le peuple et où
les deux ne s'entendent plus on a on a
un gouvernement qui a enfermé dans son
dogmatisme et qui veut absolument faire
passer au forceps toutes ces réformes
et quitte à user de loi aussi
autoritaire et d'un autre côté une
partie de la population j'ai envie de
dire une grande majorité de la
population qui ne se reconnaît plus dans
toutes ses toutes ces réformes est qui
qui souhaitent s'opposer à tout ça est
la seule réponse qu qu'on lui apporte
c'est la matraque il ya plus de il ya
plus de discussions là dedans et donc
forcément avec cette tension qui qui
grandit les rapports sont de plus en
plus violents et nécessairement la
police est aussi la police est de plus
en plus violentes et ces mêmes des
débordements voilà on constate de plus
en plus de débordements
de par cette tension alors venez le
micro lui se défend de toute dérive
autoritaire pas seulement pour cette
manifestation du 12 décembre mais en
général d'ailleurs il avait dit abrutyn
le 4 décembre n'est pas la hongrie ou la
turquie qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
cette défense du président de la
république mais j'ai pas envie que mon
pays j'ai pas envie que la france
devienne non plus la turquie la turquie
la hongrie ou la corée du nord donc
justement c'est pour ça je suis dans la
rue pour me battre pour nos libertés et
quand je constate effectivement quelle
ces dérives la de la police est basse et
fortement inquiétant je vois pas
pourquoi on devrait se comparer
justement ou pas ou quand de farouk
enfin au pays les mois les moins porté
sur la démocratie justement si on aime
démocratie il faut la défendre jusqu'au
bout
merci beaucoup en tout cas l'ex niveau
de l'un d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france